[Music]
from the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
they are investigating a
fatal accident on Tuesday
morning how about health to Cristian
Cásseres I tell you that this happened
around one in the morning over
exaggerates and towards at least one person
died and  It is believed that the suspect in
this accident was driving drunk at
the moment this case is still under
investigation
and I tell you that the police are
looking for a man suspected of
shooting a waiter several times the
victim is fighting for his life in the
hospital the shooting  It happened on
Monday morning in the Chinatown area, the
authorities said that a person
entered the restaurant and shot 0
11 times. That place plans to open its
doors to donate all the proceeds in
this way to help with the expenses for the
waiter and  his family haji's national league
decided to suspend several games
due to positive cases of kobe in the
players in addition to the 10 of the 32
teams  The teams that make up the league
have their calendars already interrupted and
their stadiums closed. The 2 games
scheduled for Tuesday are still
active, however those scheduled
for Wednesday until Saturday will be
postponed and we take a look at the
temperatures as we can see here
with your  weather forecast we will see
some clouds however we will have a
clear sky with temperatures almost
reaching 60 degrees i am cristian
cáceres with his start informative award
in spanish
[Music]